♪♪♪♪
-A visual effect is kind of like
a special effect
except it happens
in the computer.
-On this show, the term "visua
effects" is a pretty broad one
It could be everything
from green-screen compositing,
3-D animation, 2-D animation
a title popping on the screen.
-One of the challenges with ou
timetable is that we have to
create all these effects
in a 10-hour span
but still make it look
good enough for television
-It's different from other
production environments in which
you might have weeks or months
to create something.
Here we have hours,
sometimes even minutes.
-We have to kind of
pace ourselves out,
and even while the show's
airing, we're still
making changes to pieces
that will air later in the show.
We're working until
the very last piece airs.
-We add people's heads
getting cut off.
We add and remove things
that otherwise
wouldn't be able to happen
on set.
-Our week starts on Wednesda
when we get the scripts.
-We go through
and kind of collaborate
through a shared document,
and we all take a look
at the script, figure out
which graphics they're gonna be.
While the shoot's
going on on Fridays,
we're working with our
designers, Marissa and Leigh
-We're in charge of the look
or anything that falls
into the "graphic" categor
for the film shoots.
In terms of VFX,
we do the titling.
-I design a shot where there's
like four Popsicle sticks
that look like rocketships
and there's smoke coming off
the bottom of them.
The VFX guys take that
and make it look like
the Popsicles are flying off
-Definitely one of my favorites.
-It's always gonna look better
when we're on set
because we get to communicat
with the director in a way
that otherwise
we wouldn't be able to.
So, we're on the set
of "Chad's Journey."
This entire set's
gonna become Heaven.
-There was
a Kellyanne Conway spoof
in which she was depicted as It.
We actually were able to b
there with the rain machines
and everything
and helping frame the shot
so that they would work well
for our post-production process.
-When we get in
on Saturday mornings,
we usually arrive around
10:00 in the morning,
and we'll usually walk
into a rough cut.
Typically from the moment
we get in until dress rehearsal,
we have about 12 hours
to start working on everything
and the cut is still in progress
while we're doing it.
-4:00 is when we get
roughly a locked edit.
Really, that's when we know fo
sure this shot's gonna be in
this is gonna be in
the actual thing for sure,
so we definitely have to
put on our thinking caps
and think creatively about
how we're gonna get it done.
-We also have to
be really flexible
and ready to change things
on the fly because sometimes
a writer or director
will see something
and want to push
the effect further.
-You know, one of the things
that's really exciting
and fun about working here
is that the requests
are so diverse.
There's a lot of different way
that you can interpret
a visual-effects
or graphics request.
And since
we're sort of emulating
so many different styles
and we're sort of aping
the look of advertisements
and films and things like that
we have to be able
to sort of adapt
to the look and feel
of these things
that come from all these
different sources.
I always like working with
the performance of the cas
because, to me, that's
sort of the meat of the show
It's a lot of fun
when the cast members themselves
kind of get into it
and really embrace
the portion of that
that is the performance
that we can then marry
with the effect.
In "The Chosen One,"
we made Kenan into a centaur
and he was able
to kind of move his body
in a way that felt like
a horse walking,
even though he was
just on a green screen.
And once we took that tors
and kind of married it
to our prop horse,
it really helped
to sell the effect.
-You know those challenges
on reality shows
where they have to, like,
bake a cake?
They do the countdown.
It's like, "Okay, everyone
There's five seconds left.
That's what it feels like
every week,
and it's actually a lot of fun
-Yeah.
-It's definitely
continuing to grow.
Whatever we can do to try
to get it done faster.
-We're working on stuff
that just hours later
we're gonna see air
live on television,
and it's really exciting
to see that instant,
like, gratification.
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ Yeah, whoa ♪♪
♪♪ Yeah, whoa ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ Here we go ♪♪
♪♪ Here we go, here we go
♪♪ Ohh ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ Let the people take the mos
and just go ♪♪
♪♪ Yeah ♪♪
♪♪ Explode ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ Oh, no, you didn't ♪♪
♪♪ But I think that you did
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ Here we go again and agai
and again and again and again
♪♪ Ahhhhh ♪♪
♪♪ Let the people take the mos
and just go ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ Explode ♪♪
♪♪ Let me tell you something
♪♪ Living your dreams ♪♪
♪♪ Thanks for the serotonin
♪♪ We're going insane ♪♪
♪♪ Ahh, ahh ♪♪
♪♪ There we go, there we g
there we go again ♪♪
♪♪ You did it, you did it,
you did it ♪♪
♪♪ Oh, no, you don't,
oh, yes, you did ♪♪
♪♪ Ahh, whoa ♪♪
♪♪ Come on ♪♪
♪♪ Give me the goods,
give me the goods ♪♪
I know you got 'em ♪♪
♪♪ Give me the goods,
give me the goods ♪♪
I know you got 'em ♪♪
♪♪ Yeah, no, whoa ♪♪
♪♪ Yes, no, whoa ♪♪
♪♪ Yeahhh ♪♪
♪♪ I can't believe
you're doing the thing ♪♪
♪♪ I can't believe you're
doing your thing ♪♪
♪♪ Come on, come on ♪♪
♪♪ And stop ♪♪